Now that you've decided how to
structure your data, it's time to write
the code that will write these shopping
list items into the correct location and
read them as well.
Okay, so on our shopping list page we
currently have a useless button for
adding more items.
When I click Add Item here it
doesn't really do anything.
Here's what I want you to do.
When you click the fab and you enter
the name of the item, and you press
Add Item, what it should do is it should
see what shopping list you're on.
Go to a node called shopping list items.
Use the push ID for the shopping
list that you're currently on, and
create an item under that push ID.
Did you catch all that?
Let me show you a quick example.
Say I've got a shopping list
with the push ID, 1234.
When I want to add a new item,
such as bacon to this shopping list,
it'll go to this node
shopping list items,
make a node with the same key
as the shopping list up here.
And then put the bacon item there.
If I wanted to add lettuce and tomato
to the same list, with the key 1234,
they would also be added to the node
shopping list items, with the child one,
two, three, four.
Now, you might have noticed that I
didn't tell you what the keys for
these would be.
What you want to make these keys
is up for you to figure out.
And just to drive what's going on home,
let's say that I have another list
with the push key 1999, and
I wanted to add cooking oil.
That would look like this.
Instead of adding it onto
the list of items in 1234,
you would go to the list 1999 and
make a new item there.
Getting the data to add in the correct
place is the trickiest part of this
exercise.
Remember that you should
have saved the list ID in
a member variable called mListID.
Just like when we started to
have multiple shopping lists,
start by just getting the data to
appear in the Firebase back end.
Once you've got the data correctly
adding itself in the back end, then you
should set up a Firebase list adaptor
that will display your items here.
This actually really isn't much
different than when we added
the Firebase list adaptor in
the shopping list fragment.
So you can refer to that if you need to.
I'll send over the spec now.
And finally, sorry, before I forget.
You should remember also that when you
delete a list, using this Remove dialog,
that it should also delete all the items
that are associated with the list.
Okay, good luck.